when editing CSS the dev tools you can
now easily increment or decrement values
using some new shortcuts we've added in
the sources pain you can use fault up
for all down increment or decrement x
value 1 you can also use all page up or
page down to increment or decrement x
value of 10 now let's say that you love
working the omelet Spain where you're
probably used to inspecting an element
and then going to these Styles pains
actually go and play around with values
well you can go and find a property to
work with and similar to what you're
used to you can still use the up and
down keys to increment or decrement x
value 1 you can also now increment x
value 10 or decrement using shift up or
shift down and using shift page up or
ship page down you can increment or
decrement x value of a hundred and
finally those ultra specific properties
you can use alt up and on down to
increment or decrement x value of
certain point one